Hello, I'm William Zaloga.
I'm a DO pathologist,
and this is a discussion
of the pathology of soft
tissues. And we're going
to go over what components
of the soft tissues that
we'll be looking at today.
We aren't going to go
over all of them, but ones
that are important, or
common, or significant.
Here's my email. I'm
at the Arkansas campus.
Feel free to send me
comments or questions.
But if you're here
in Arkansas, you
can just come up to
room 424F, which is
my office, or give
me a phone call.
My number in the
office is 870-680-8899.
And
here's the session objectives.
And these are the components
of the soft tissues
that we'll be considering
today and having a
discussion about. Now, we'll
be talking about tumors
of adipocytes, and when
you see OMA at the end
of a tumor, that usually
indicates a benign type
of tumor, and when you
see sarcoma, that's
going to be the malignant
component of that tumor.
And that's how mesenchymal
cell tumors are usually
classified when it comes
to benign and malignant.
we're also going to look
at fibroblasts and fibrous
tissue and some of the
tumors that develop from
that from benign conditions
like nodular fasciitis up
to fibrosarcoma we'll be
looking at skeletal muscle
and that's indicated
by the prefix rhabdo so
rhabdomyo and then sarcoma
are going to be skeletal
malignant tumors of skeletal
muscle differentiation.
And here you can see
there's many, a few
variants that we're
going to talk about.
These two tumors, number four
and number five objectives,
don't have a cell of origin
that can be, that has been
identified yet. Even though
this says synovial sarcoma,
the structures around the
synovium or synoviocytes
are not the tissue of origin.
And we'll discuss that.
We're going to look
at undifferentiated
pleomorphic sarcoma
as well. So as you can
tell, this is a very
unusual looking tumor.
It's not differentiated,
so the cell of
origin there is not
fully classified yet.
And here's just another
list that just talks
about what we just talked
about with adipocytic
type tumors,
fibroblastic type tumors,
and skeletal muscle tumors, and
unknown origin type of tumors.
So that's going to
be our focus today.
This slide just goes over
some general features of
malignant and benign tumors
and how we classify those.
Malignant tumors
are usually rare.
They are less than
1% of all cancers,
but they are
usually aggressive.
The benign tumors are
much more common, 100 to
1, except for the skeletal
muscle and hip load.
Most are in the extremities,
especially the thigh,
15% in children.
This is a common
presentation, a growing mass.
So as you can imagine,
studies are needed in order
to determine is this
a mass that we need to
do something about
significant? Do we need to
excise it? Do we just need
to get a biopsy? Is it
something that we shouldn't
be concerned about?
Sometimes they're painful
and sometimes there's
loss of range of motion
due to the structures
involved and the size
of tumor location.
Most are sporadic and
minority are associated
with mutations of
tumor suppressor genes.
For example, Gardner
syndrome associated with this
and these others that
we're not going to talk
about tumors that develop
in those. We'll talk
about Gardner syndrome. Some
are linked to environmental
exposures like radiation
burns and toxins.
Chronic inflammation is
also a feature that can
produce changes in mutations
that may lead to tumors.
So most of these arise from
a pluripotent mesenchymal
stem cell that gets some
sort of driver mutation.
So the benign and the
malignant ones will have some
sort of mutation that's
producing abnormal growth,
dysregulation of that growth.
The majority have
complex karyotypes with
multiple chromosome
gains and losses.
Some have simple
karyotypes like senovial
sarcoma, and we'll be
talking about that one. So,
to classify these,
we're going to have to
observe it morphologically
under the microscope.
We'll have to do
immunohistochemistry, usually, and
those are also known as
stains or special stains of
the tissue sections that
we take from these tumors.
Molecular diagnostics
are going to be important
in order to come confirm
certain diagnoses.
And the grade and the
stage is important.
Remember, the grade
is how it looks. Does
it look aggressive?
Is it very anaplastic?
And the stage is
going to be where it's
located. So is it isolated
to tissue of origin
or is it already
spread to other tissues
or invading other
tissues that are nearby.
And these all produce
important prognostic
indicators for
treatment outcomes.
And this is a good
slide. We're not
going to be talking
about all of these.
We're going to point
them out. Well,
because these are showing
some of the known mutations
of the chromosomes, and
some of them are not
well characterized, or
they have multiple varying
mutations that can be found
in those types of tumors.
Some, like this, have a
characteristic mutation.
For example, we'll
be talking about
liposarcoma, and that's
a translocation 1216.
synovial sarcoma, that's
an X18 translocation,
rhabdomyosarcoma, the
alveolar type, and there's
two different translocations
that are characteristic
there. And over here,
we show the function
of these genes that
produce various proteins
and the proposed function
of the mutation change.
We're going to talk about
infantile fibrosarcoma,
and you see the translocation
there that's been
identified consistently,
and nodular fasciitis, which
is technically a benign
tumor. It usually can be
locally invasive, but
usually stays in that spot
and doesn't metastasize to
other places. But it does
have a characteristic
translocation, shown here.
And that produces various
abnormal signaling
that leads to
abnormal growth, okay?
And here's another
useful slide.
It goes over general categories
that we'll be talking about.
Adipose, fibrous tissue,
skeletal muscle, not smooth
muscle, not vascular tumors,
not nerve sheet tumors.
So see, we're not going
to talk about all the soft
issues, but we'll be talking
about the uncertainty histotype
tumors not the benign one
but these malignant ones
synovial sarcoma and
undifferentiated and the reason
this is helpful is because
it goes over the demographics
of where these tumors
commonly occur which will
give you a clue to what you
should be looking for and
just helps with your
diagnosis so and and this is a
useful slide because it's
all contained in this one
slide, and it would be good
to just review this many times
and see that alveolar
rhabdomyosarcoma, although
we're going to have details
in the presentation, occurs
at young age with embryonal
rhabdomyosarcoma occurring
at even younger ages and
the ******* urinary tract.
undifferentiated pleomorphic
sickoma occurs in
middle-aged older adults
and commonly in the thigh
and when we do take a
look at this these are
some of the types of
tumor characteristics that
will be characteristic
of that lesion so it
would be good for the ones
we're going to be talking
about to review this
as a nice summary okay
first we're going to go
over some normal tissue and
the types of cells that
make them up so here are
some soft tissue cells
that occur this is adipose
tissue and you can see
we have a cell with clear
cytoplasm because that
contains lipids and when we
prepare the slides in
the tissue processing
machine the lipids are
washed out and left with
clear space. So lipids
were contained in
here. Here's the cell
membrane and you can see
it has a small dark
nucleus at the periphery.
Here are fibroblastic
types of cells and you
can see these types of
cells, fibroblastic,
here's skeletal muscle,
and here is, no this
skeletal muscle sorry
this is going to be okay
all right so so these are
fibroblasts as you can
see that they have a what's
called a spindle-shaped
nucleus and they will
characteristically commonly
either be rounded with
the spindle-shaped cells
elongated ends pointy ends
and a nucleus I guess it
also has the same kind of
characteristic features.
It's a spindle shape
or cigar shape,
but it will have
pointy ends, whereas
this here looks
like smooth muscle,
they'll be spindle
shaped cells as well.
But the nuclei will be
within the cell and be cigar
shaped or spindle shaped,
but with rounded ends.
And if that is
confusing when you
actually get a tissue section,
there are special
stains you can do for
smooth muscle actin and
for fibroblasts, too.
If you don't know, then
you need to confirm it.
And here's skeletal muscle.
Characteristically, these
are multi-nucleated, long
cylindrical cells. And
they'll have peripherally
located spindle shape
nuclei, multiple ones, and
they have a characteristic
striate, cross striations
produced by the actin and
myosin filaments within
the cell, and so that
indicates skeletal muscle.
Let's get started talking
about these tumors.
The lipoma, that's a benign
adipose tissue tumor.
it's most commonly the
most common soft tissue
tumor in the adults.
Commonly it's located in the
below the epidermis of
the proximal extremities
or the trunk in
middle age individuals
and a sign of something
being benign is going
to be mobility It can
be moved around. It's
not invading and fixing
to other tissues,
usually painless and
cured by simple excision.
Another feature of some
tumor being benign is that
you'll find that it's well
encapsulated and it looks mature.
It's just abnormal growth
of mature looking cells.
Here
is a gross image of
an excised tumor.
And you see that
it's located just
below the epidermis
and the subcutis.
And it can be lobulated.
It's going to look yellow
because it's adipose
tissue. It's going to be
soft. And it looks well
encapsulated. Remember,
that's a characteristic of
a benign tumor. And when
we talk about a capsule,
it's this thin fibrous
layer that's surrounding
the tumor, as we can see
here, around all these
mature-looking adipocytes.
Some tumors will look
pseudo-encapsulated
because as they expand,
they just compress
the tissue around
them, and it looks
like a capsule. So,
but it's actually not.
But the lipoma has a
well-formed fibrous
capsule. And those
capsules, the capsule
contains the tumor
within that local region.
And that's one of the signs of
a tumor having a
benign quality.
Now we're going to
look at liposarcoma.
All right, the liposarcoma
is the malignant
adipose tissue tumor
and the most common
sarcomas, and remember
sarcomas are rare,
but it's the most
common of adulthood.
And this is the usual
location and that
would be the extremities
or the retroperitoneum
and located deep
in the soft tissue.
And here's the
age range, that's
typical. There will be pain,
it will be soft, there will be
swelling, there
will be fatigue,
depending on how big it
is, where it's located,
there could be a loss of
range of motion or decrease.
There's three distinct
subtypes of a liposarcoma.
The well differentiated one,
and the myxoid, and
the pleomorphic, and
here's some of the
description of some of
the abnormalities you
find in these tumors.
they have different
genetic aberrations.
Well differentiated,
as you can imagine,
you'll find well-differentiated
adipocytes. You'll
also find something called
a lipoblast, which is an
immature adipocyte that has
a larger nucleus that's just
early on in its differentiation
that hasn't produced
a lot of lipids yet in
the cytoplasm, and those
will have amplification of
this region of this chromosome,
and that includes P53,
the P53 inhibitor, MDM2.
Mixoid liposarcoma
has a fusion gene
in this characteristic
translocation
that arrests adipocyte
differentiation,
and it leads to unregulated
proliferation of
primitive cells.
Then there's
pleomorphic liposarcoma,
pleomorphic means odd
looking tumor cells with
various shapes and sizes
that are not normal,
they're malignant.
They'll have a complex
karyotype without reproducible
abnormalities, genetic
abnormalities that
are found in all of these
leomorphic liposarcomas.
Okay, the well-differentiated,
as I said, will
have mature lipocytes and
scattered atypical ones,
the lipoplasts. The
myxoid liposarcoma
will have abundant
basophilic on H&E stain,
extracellular matrix
material, which consists
of mucopolysaccharides
that have accumulated
in the stroma surrounding
the tumor cells.
There'll be arborizing
capillaries, which sometimes
are referred to as having
a chicken wire appearance
because the chicken wire
is that wire fencing that
goes around chicken pens
to contain the chickens.
And primitive cells
in various stages of
differentiation. The pleomorphic
liposarcoma will have
spindle cells, and they'll
be high-grade, which
means that they'll be very,
very abnormal-looking.
And some of them will
be anaplastic, which
means that there's no
way of telling what
kind of differentiation
those cells have,
even though you
identify it as a
liposarcoma, because
you probably found some
cells that are
consistent with that.
and a bizarre nuclei mixed
with occasional immature,
had to slice the lipovaskan,
and a characteristic of a
malignant type of tumor is
going to be that it rapidly
grows and invades other
tissues, and so that rapid
growth is going to lead it
to outstrip its blood supply
with necrosis occurring in
that tumor and hemorrhage.
It contains less fatty tissue
than a well-differentiated one,
and it's usually, well,
it's not encapsulated.
It stains for S100, S100 is a
stain that will
stain adipocytes,
and it's negative
for keratin which
will stain epithelial
type cells,
and desmin will stain
muscle type cells.
Unless it's adequately
excised, which can be difficult
because it is invasive,
it may recur locally.
The well-differentiated
are inlet and
slow-growing and
tend not to invade
but tend not to metastase.
Pleomorphic ones
are aggressive with
frequent metastases.
Myxoid tumors are in the
middle between those extremes.
Now here's a myxoid tumor.
This is the tumor
right here, and you see
it's a multi-lobulated
and it's, you know,
here's a part of it
that has grown into
the muscles that this
tumor was founded.
So they removed
this muscle so that
they would have wide
margins. So they
knew they would
have all the tumor.
These These are some
characteristics of it, lobulated,
gray-white, and it's
within skeletal muscle.
So it's myxoid, so you
get this pale blue-purple
material within the stroma
between the adipocytes.
And you can see the
adipocytes here. Some of
them look like lipoblasts
occasionally that are
immature cells that
haven't developed the full
ability to become a mature
lipoblast like these
with a small nucleus,
purpley, and a large lipid,
and a bunch of
lipid and cytoplasm.
And it shows this delicate
capillary network,
and they call this a
chicken wire appearance.
This looks like some
of the wire that
they use to make
chicken tubes out of.
Here is a pliomorphic
liposarcoma, and
once again it's within
the skeletal muscle.
And you can see that it's
invasive into the surrounding
adjacent tissue of the
skeletal muscle down here.
It has areas of necrosis,
you see it's empty space
where it looks like there
was some hemorrhage in
there too. And then this
is fat necrosis that has
occurred. It usually has a
bright, lobulated appearance.
Okay.
And you can see the
term pleomorphic is very
appropriate because
you have some cells
that may be adipocytes,
but this has a highly
unusual nucleus,
multilobulated, irregular,
very hyperchromatic. Some
of them you can see there's
a lot of different sizes
and shapes and they're
dark and they're angulated
this one has multiple lobes
and it is producing some
lipids in an abnormal
manner and see this one
down here dark nucleus and
creating a little bit of
lipid in the cytoplasm so
various sizes and shapes
that's what pleomorphic is and
I showed you the scattered
lipoblasts here's one.
Okay, the lipoblast, okay,
and it'll have a dark,
larger nucleus than the
mature adipocytes and
it has begun the process
of becoming an adipocyte
by producing some
lipids within the cytoplasm,
but still immature,
okay, and then these lipid
droplets are creating
this kerbs nuclear surface
that's called scalloping,
and here's a common
location. It's going to occur
in the lower extremity,
usually in the muscles.
And this is about the
age range that you would
find that in as well,
in the person as well,
young adult or
middle-aged adult.
Here's a question, and
the answer is going
to be on the next slide.
And we can just look
at some of this real
quick, so maybe try to
answer it before you
go look at the answer.
Large fatty tumor,
retroperitoneum, 55 years
old. See, so that's
why demographics are
important, because this
is stuff that the surgeon
is going to tell you,
or you're going to get
it from some kind of
report, from some doctor.
The tumor is found to
be malignant, adipose
tissue, and diagnosed as
a pleomorphic liposarcoma,
which is going to describe
the, which is going to be
a description you would
find in this type of tumor.
and the answer will be here.
Okay.
And so the answer is
right here, plenomorphic
liposarcoma. So if you
remember some of the features,
you know that that's not
the mixoid, liposarcoma.
Lipoblasts are likely to
be present. I just showed
you lipoblasts. Cured by
simple excision, that would
be lipoma, and this is a
malignant tumor, sarcoma.
It's well encapsulated.
That's a signal of a
benign type of tumor, mature
adipocytes. Once again,
that will be no. And
no genetic apparitions.
Yes, this is a mass of
tissue that is undergoing
unregulated cell growth.
And so there will be a
genetic apparition that's
producing that effect.
Okay, now we're done
with the adipose tissue.
Now we're going to talk
about, okay, fibroblasts.
We'll start with benign,
this is malignant,
which seems to be the
pattern that we usually do.
We have nodular
fasciitis. It sounds
like an inflammatory
process, right?
So, it is a benign
tumor. It's self-limited
fibroblastic and
myofibroblastic proliferation.
And these are like
fibroblastic except
they have some spoon
muscle actin within the
cytoplasm that allows
them to be contractile.
Okay,
characteristics,
so demographics are important.
Young adults,
usually full arm, chest,
back, firm, fixed, rubbery,
solid, can be tender if
you touch it, and it grows
rapidly over weeks to months,
usually history of trauma.
Once not to be reactive,
okay,
however, here's an odd
thing. It was discovered
to have a clonal
proliferation of cells with
this translocation identified
within those cells.
And that produces a fusion
of the myosin heavy chain
and this other enzyme that
controls, regulates cell
function and produces this
abnormal proliferation.
It's not known, so these
are neoplastic cells. It's
not known why these
neoplastic cells don't become
malignant. But they don't. It
usually regresses, and if it
is excised, it rarely comes
back, and these are the
locations where we'll find
it within the body, below the
epidermis, the subcutis,
you know, just below the
epidermis, this is deep
dermis, fascia, or the muscles.
Okay,
a little bit more about
nodular fasciitis when we
look at the excised
tumor. What we see is it's
usually not encapsulated,
and gross just means what
it looks like not magnified
just with your eye.
If you look at the
legion, not encapsulated
but will circumscribe.
It is fast growing so
it's going to push the
other tissues around
it and that's going to
contain it somewhat.
So it could be a little
infiltrated though. These
usually tend to remain small
and what you see if you
do magnify it and stain it
is plump immature appearing
fibroblasts so they
are proliferating and
myofibroblasts with elongated
nuclei okay those are
spindle shaped and punctate
nucleolide which means they
are active okay now frequent
mitosis none of those
are abnormal looking though
there are two different
regions you can find one
is hypercellular and one
is hypocellular And the
hypocellular one has a
fibrostroma, so that's the
cell surrounding the tumor.
And this hypocellular
has a myxoid-type
stroma, and this
is called zonation.
Storyform and vesicular
patterns are common
in those cellular areas.
And storyform this
means a swirling
pattern of tumor cells.
And vesicular patterns
are going to be
those strips of parallel
cells, various strips
of those that you'll
find in the tumor.
and see here infiltrating
lymphocytes are common which
prompted people to think
it was a reactive process
okay here
are some here is
an H&E image and
the arrowheads are
pointing to these
mitoses, you see this dark
line, so this would be a
metaphase cell with all the
chromosomes aligned at the
metaphase plate. And that's
how it's supposed to look.
You do see a lot of cells
randomly oriented and
proliferating. This is called
a tissue culture appearance.
And it says up here that
extravasated red cells
you'll find commonly, but I
looked and I saw one right
here, but I really didn't
see any of this. no
but I guess they do appear
so here's some extravasated
red cells there's one
there maybe there okay all
right moving on to
superficial fibromatosis all
right superficial fibromatosis
is as you can imagine
if there's a superficial
one it's probably a deep
one and we'll go over that
one next the superficial
one tends to be benign
and resolve spontaneously
the deep one tends to be
more invasive and can be
more aggressive and we'll
talk about why that is
okay if you and the
males are gonna be more
commonly affected
than female but you It
usually causes local
deformity, and here's
several regions where
this is common to occur.
Painless, firm,
subcutaneous induration.
It can produce, in
the example of Palmer
fibromatosis, as it
progresses, it might
attach to the skin and
produce dimpling and
slowly progressive
flexion contracture.
So, it's going to be
an irregular thickening
of palmar fascia. It can
be one or both hands.
There will be ill
-defined long fascicles
with a lot of abundant
dense collagen.
And the fascicles
are going to consist
of plump spindle
cells, fibroblasts.
It tends to be nodular
and proliferative.
You see that there's
other regions besides the
palm. that's called
dupytrans contracture.
There's leader-host
disease that occurs on the
foot, and that usually
occurs with young boys,
while dupytrans usually
increases in
incidence with age.
It's usually unilateral,
does not cause contractures.
It can be associated
with the other types of
fibromatosis. There's another
one called ****** fibromatosis,
that's Peyronie disease,
and that'll be a mass of
this tissue on the dorsolateral
aspect of the *****
can cause abnormal curvature
and constriction of
the urethra. Some of them
will resolve spontaneously.
The palmar and the
plantar one tend
to progress in about
half the cases.
The reason that
this is going to be
not as aggressive
as the deep one,
which we're going
to talk about next,
well, after we're done here,
is there are certain
mutations in genes that
occur in the deep one that
seems like they should
be occurring in the
superficial one because
morphologically under
the microscope they look
just about alike. It's
just one's deep, one's
superficial, and the
deep one is usually more
invasive probably because
it has these mutations.
There hasn't been
a well-defined
mutation bound for superficial.
It doesn't have, for
example, APC and beta
-catenin gene mutations
that you find in the deep.
But there is some abnormality.
Researchers have found
focal accumulation
of beta-catenin in some of the
cells. But its
significance is unclear.
Okay, so here's
some images of what
you might find in
Dupu-transcontractor.
Here you don't see
dimpling and nodular
thickening of the palm.
Here you do see that
dimpling, and you can
tell his fingers are
contracted somewhat
in a flexion position.
This is what you'll see
if you do an H&E stain
from a resected nodule,
which is what we see
here. This is the
resection, and it looks like
fibrous tissue. It's tan
gray in front of them,
or tan white and fur,
and what is described is
irregular fascicles, maybe
here, maybe here, and
lots of collagen, and
those are going to consist
of fibroblasts, and all
this pink material that
is surrounding these
fascicles, that's collagen.
So similar to a scar.
And this is the muscle
that is adjacent to it.
And then here's
deep fibromatosis.
Okay, the deep fibromatosis
is also called a desmoid.
They are also called desmoid
tumors. They tend to get
a larger, averaging about
10 centimeters, and they can
be infiltrative. They
frequently occur, but don't
metastasize, and it will be
mostly women that will be
affected. Women in their teens
all the way into the 30s.
Abdominal location
is common, and in the
musculo-aponeurotic
structures of the anterior
lateral abdominal wall.
Also, the shoulder,
and the pelvis, the
hips, and the mesentery.
And here's those mutations,
I was talking about
the APC and beta-catenin
genes, they both lead to
increased WNT signaling,
which drives growth, and
the majority have sporadic
beta-catenin mutations,
but individuals with familial
adenomatous polyposis,
which can be produced by
germline mutations in APC and
Gardner syndrome are predisposed
to deep fibromatosis.
Okay, a little bit more
about deep fibromatosis.
This is what you'll
see if it is removed.
A gray, white, firm,
poorly debarcated
mass and an average of
about 10 centimeters.
Rubbery, tough, fixed, just
like fibrous tissue. It
tends to infiltrate the
surrounding structures, muscles,
nerves, fat, so it can be
painful and disfiguring.
Blancroscopic, bland fibroblast,
long parallel fascicles,
dense collagen, no cellular
atypia, no mitosis,
looks like a scar and also
like superficial fibromatosis,
but a bit more aggressive.
they're infiltrative
because of this complete
excision can sometimes be
difficult due to this local
infiltration into adjacent
muscle but they don't spread
to other areas of the bodies
but they can be aggressive
acting kind of like cancer
so often oncologists care
for these patients here's
some images of deep
fibromatosis here's
a gross image showing
the cut surface
there's a lack of
encapsulation so you can see
there's some infiltration
this is the muscle
into the adjacent muscle
and fat tissue by fibrous
type tissue and this is
what you'll see those
fascicles and there'll be
lots of pink stuff that's
incorporated in this tumor
mass and that's the collagen
and here it is It's
invading and surrounding
adjacent structures. In this
case, it's invading into
adjacent adipose tissue
and skeletal muscle that
we can see here with its
peripheral nuclei and the
tumor fibrous tissue is
invading into that muscle.
Okay, now fibrosarcoma,
this is the
malignant form of
fibroblast tumor. And
now fibrosarcoma,
these are rare
malignant tumors
of the fibroblasts.
Most patients are going
to be in their middle
ages, two types. The infantile
type rarely metastasizes.
The adult type
frequently metastasizes,
commonly to the lung and
bone. More if it's highly
cellular and there's a
lot of mycotic activity.
This is the usual
location, the deep soft
tissues of the lower
extremity or the trunk. It
can be painful and
it's fixed because it's
invading other structures.
It's going to be soft
and you might find an
unexplained weight loss
with this rapidly growing
and invading tumor.
Many of the older cases
called fibrosarcoma were
actually differentiated
other types of tumors. And as
doctors became more familiar
with these different
types of tumors, how to
identify them specifically,
these fibromyalgia
were reclassified
as these other types of tumors.
This is viable at five
years, it is overall
about 41. At 10 years,
about 29 percent.
It's a diagnosis of exclusion.
there's going to need to be
immunohistochemistry
molecular studies
to identify the subtypes it
may appear well circumscribed
but it's not encapsulated
and it's going to be
because it's a malignant
tumor it's going to be
fleshy it's going to be
hemorrhagic not because it's a
malignant tumor not all
of them are fleshy it just
looks like what's called
fish flesh when it's on the
cut surface hemorrhagic
because of the rapid growth
and stripping its blood
supply, necrotic and because
it's fibrous tissue, white
and tan and invasive.
This is going to be,
if you look under the
microscope, highly
cellular and there'll be
a characteristic
pattern which will be a
herringbone pattern
with variable collagen.
Okay, They're going to
be long, dark nuclei,
increased chromatin,
variable nucleoli,
myctonic activity is
going to be present,
and they'll be often
looked at normal.
It stays positive for vimentin,
since it's a mesenchymal
type tumor, and it's
going to be negative for
S100, and for cytokarotins,
which is positive in
adipocytes, and it's positive
in epithelial type cells.
So you would use
those to exclude the
other types of
tumors if you were
having trouble
identifying it with H&E.
Treatments will require
radical excision
and radiation if
there's any positive
margins. The margins
are just the edges.
If there's tumor at the
edge, that means you might
have left some where you
found the tumor at surgery.
Possibly chemotherapy
if it looks high
grade, if those nuclei
are very irregular.
Definitive cause is
not identified because
there's variable gene
mutations and there are
predisposing factors like
sites of prior injury.
I mentioned chronic
inflammation before because
of the chances of that
injury and repair is going
to create the possibility
of a mutation occurring.
Irradiated tissue, same
sort of thing. and a pre
-existing well-differentiated
glyphosarcoma. So
that can be de-differentiated
into fibrosarcoma. So
these are images of excised
fibrosarcoma. And as you
can see on the surface, it
does look like fish flesh.
This one was removed from
muscle. This was removed
from muscle as well.
And here it looks even
more invasive into the
surrounding muscles. And it's
called pseudo-encapsulated
because it grows very
rapidly and compresses
the tissue around it. So
when you look under the
microscope, it looks
like it's a capsulator.
It doesn't have that thin
fibrous structure around
the tumor containing it.
And this is microscopic images
that shows what's called
the herringbone pattern.
So this is a good clue that
you are dealing with fibrous
sarcoma microscopically.
there will be increased
nuclear to cytoplasmic ratio.
Normally for regular cells
that ratio is about 1 to
4. So nuclear size to
cytoplasmic size. 1 to 4 or
1 to 6. Up to 1 to 6. But
it can approach 1 to 1
so that means there's a
big nucleus not a lot of
cytoplasm in those cells.
That's one of the signs of
malignancy and high what's
called nc ratio and this
is demonstrating that
hyperchromasia of the nuclei
is another you see very
dark irregular looking
nuclei this one looks spino
this one looks kind of
square this was rectangular
this one is very dark and
polygonal here's one that
looks a bit tapered so
this one has a bit of
pleomorphism within
this tumor demonstrating
the features
of a malignant tumor,
hypotriotic nuclei,
and increased nuclear-to
-cytoplasmic ratio. Let me
just look at this one here,
and this looks like this
might be all the cytoplasmic
there is, and here's
a big nucleus, so it's
about one to one, I'd say.
Now, we're going to
talk about skeletal
muscle malignant tumors,
rhabdomyosarcoma.
Once again, these are rare
malignant mesenchymal tumors.
With skeletal muscle
differentiation, it's the
most common soft tissue
sarcoma of childhood,
usually starting
in muscle tissue.
There's four subtypes,
and there's this one here.
Alveolar and embrionol
is most common
in pleomorphic, but
if you look down
here, which I should
have put up there,
you'll see that sarcoma
betroides is a subtype of
embrionol, rapid myosarcoma.
So there's the fourth one.
So disease of
childhood, so remember
that, usually below
the age of 18.
It's a quickly
growing mass with pain
and unexplained weight
loss. So remember
those characteristics
in the ages.
Alveolar and embryonal
subtypes are usually
childhood and adolescence,
usually before 20.
Alveolar is usually
older kids, 20 to 35,
and that's going to
be occurring on the
arms, legs, and the
trunks. Remember those
demographics as well
for this subtype.
Pediatric rhabdomyosarcoma,
so occurring at
a young age, tend to
occur in the *******
urinary tract, the head,
neck, and the sinuses.
Pleomorphic
rhabdomyosarcoma usually
occurs in adults
age 50 or older.
And these are usually
aggressive tumors.
You need to be treated
by surgical resection,
chemotherapy, and plus
or minus radiation,
depending on the
oncologist and surgeon.
The histologic
type and location
correlate with survival.
Sarcoma betroidis
has the most
favorable prognosis.
And good results with
treatment. Alveolar, and these
are going to be the, let's
see, the survival rate,
without remission, with
treatment, about 65%. While
the four-year survival
rate with metastasis is
only 15%. So metastasis is
worse than the prognosis.
Cleomorphics, you
know, the ones
current adults, those
are often fatal.
So, stains, as you guessed,
are going to be stains
for skeletal muscle, and
these are Desmond and
Myogenin mentioned here,
negative for the adipocyte
stain, S100, and negative
for epithelial stains,
cytokeratins, because
sometimes those epithelial
tumors can be poorly
differentiated and look
like other tumors which
are not even epithelial.
So molecular studies
are called for because
if there's this Pax
-FOXO1 fusion gene,
which interferes
with differentiation,
that's associated
with a poor survival.
So that will help you
discover and think about
what kind of treatments,
strategy you want to use.
Then here's some images.
Okay, first we'll look at
some images and a little
discussion of M. Bryan,
all rhabdomyosarcoma,
and here's a H&E stained
tissue section of a tumor.
What you find here
is primitive and some
primitive densely eosinophilic
cells that look round
without a lot of cytoplasm,
and then you see some that
are a little more
differentiated. For example, this
one here, it looks like it
is trying to produce some
skeletal muscle differentiation
with the proteins being
developed in the cytoplasm
of this one, but you
can't find too many of those.
You see the round cells
that are the primitive cells
most often in this image.
okay
rhabdomyoblasts so if you
do, if you look on high
power you might see some
prostrations and I got
another image on the next
slide that shows some
rhabdomyoblasts okay,
sarcoma petroides,
remember the best
prognosis and a disorder
of disease that
occurs in childhood,
most commonly, it's a
variant of embrinal and it
develops in the walls,
unusually in the walls of
hollow mucosaline
structures, like the vagina,
the bladder, the nasopharynx,
even in the common wild duck.
It grows in a polypoid
fashion, sometimes seen as
a cluster of grapes. So
here's a tumor that's
been removed, and an
image of some grapes in a
cluster that is similar,
so I can see why they might
say sarcoma petroides,
looks like a cluster of
grapes in a gross image
without any magnification.
And there's going to
be something called the
cambium layer which is
a dense tomb layer just
underneath the epithelium
and you can see that here.
And that's the cambium
layer in sarcoma petroides.
Next is an image of a
high-powered image of a
rhabdomyoblast and you can
see it's a primitive cell
myelotocytoplycin but
it is developing it's
producing those cross
-striations of myosin and actin
which skeletal muscle
cells do and here's the
long tubes of a cell of
normal skeletal muscle
with the peripheral spindle
-shaped nucleus and you
can see the cross
striations in the cytoplasm.
So you see, you might just
find a rare one that will
tell you that it could be
a skeletal muscle tumor
because, look at this,
this looks very high grade.
But if you find this,
that gives you more
confidence in what
you're dealing with.
Next is alveolarabdomyosarcoma,
called that
because of its
morphologic appearance,
and if you look at
this you can see how it
might resemble the
alveoli of the lungs.
On the surface of an
interconnecting network
of fibrocepta that will
create these clusters
within these alveoli,
alveolar-like
structures, are going
to be uniform and round
cells with little
cytoplasm, okay, so you
have dark nuclei, not
a lot of cytoplasm,
they all look pretty
similar, they all look like
malignant cells, and
what's called discohesive,
which means they're not
forming sheets, they don't
hold together very well,
and so you'll find some
the middle of what
looks like the
alveoli okay now
pleomorphic graph if
you look under the microscope
on it with a at an H
&E stained tissue section
of the tumor it's called
pleomorphic because you
have very regular looking
cells with irregular shapes
and sizes of the nuclei
and the cell membrane the
cytoplasm some are large
some are small high NC ratio
and there are other other
pleomorphic sarcomas which
might look like this.
So immunohistochemistry
will help because it
may be hard to find
rhabdomyoblasts because
it's so pleomorphic and
so those things would be
myogenin and desmin
which may show you that
it is indeed rhabdomyoblastic
cell of origin.
okay and then here's a
question uh the answer is the
next slide so maybe just
try to answer before you
go to the next slide or
whatever you think okay if
you look at this uh six
-year-old so it's a child
polypoid mass okay location
vagina great and grossly
it looks like grape-like
cluster of tissue, and they
discovered it's a malignant
skeletal muscle tumor.
What is the most likely
feature of this neoplasm?
And so you would have to,
in your mind, say, okay,
this is all the characters,
the demogram, there
are some features of sarcoma
vitroides, and that has
the best prognosis, it's
better than the others.
and it does have
characteristic translocation
and immunohistochemistry
is needed
to confirm fibroblast
differentiation,
but it's not needed and
it's not a fibroblast.
It says this is the
least common soft
tissue tumor of children,
sarcoma of children,
but it's not. It's
the most common.
Microscopic examination
will be of crudely
lung tissue alveoli.
Well, we just
went over that,
alveolarabdomyosarcoma.
And here's going
to be the answer.
Synoviosarcoma is
one of those tumors,
soft tissue tumors,
of uncertain origin.
Because of where it occurred,
folks in the past
believed that it was
an origin from synovial
sites or synovial
structures like
those listed here.
But further tests
show that it's
inconsistent with any
of these structures.
And in the canicary
locations, it lacks
synovium, so an uncertain
origin. But, they
tend to be in the
deep, soft tissues
adjacent to the larger
joints, like the knee,
top of the fossa,
and it usually occurs
in the 20s to 40s,
so remember the
demographics,
location, demographics,
and then we have precipitation,
deep-seated pain, numbness,
limited range of motion,
firm or fixed because it's
invasive, swelling
under the skin,
often around the
joints, or the legs I
mentioned, but it
can be the arms too.
And symptoms are
going to be similar,
arthritis, bursitis, so
people might not know
it's this and do
something about that.
So, for example,
there'll be swelling,
inflammation that can be
present for several years
before or it goes
large enough if we have
serious signs of symptoms
that are concerned.
And there's going to
be a characteristic
translocation. So
remember, between the X and
the 18 chromosome,
there's going to be a
translocation. This
produces proteins that
interfere with gene
expression of the chromatin.
So there's this
characteristic. So molecular
studies will be
helpful to confirm
diagnosis if this is
what you believe it is.
Okay,
microscopy shows two
basic types, okay,
what's called
monophasic and biphasic.
Monophasic, uniformed
spinal cells,
myelotocytoplasm, dense
chromatin, so high NC ratio,
tightly packed fascicles.
So biphasics also,
well, has a spindle, but also
has gland-like structures
with cuboidal to columnar
epithelioid cells.
So immunochemistry is
helpful, especially in the
biphasic one, because this
will help you, because
it will stay positive
for epithelial antigens.
And those are the
cytokeratins. I list some
of them here, and the
epithelial components stay
consistently positive
for CK7s and some others.
The spinosal
component is usually
bearably positive
for the cytokeratins.
It has to be
treated aggressively
with limb sprain
surgery and chemo.
Five-year survivals range
from a quarter to up to
62% related on the patient's
age, you know, over
being a poor prognostic
sign, and the tumor stage,
whether it's invaded what
tissues and metastasized.
So, in general, the
survival rate is about
50 to 60% at 5 years,
40 to 50% at 10 years.
It's lower in cases
where you've had
surgery, chemotherapy,
and it's returned
or spread to other
metastasized.
And treatment is
going to involve
surgery, chemotherapy,
and radiation.
If it's small, that
improves prognosis.
If there's few
mitosis, that improves
it. If it's easier to
move by the surgeon,
that's going to
improve prognosis.
And common signs for
metastasis are to the lung.
And unusually, for sarcomas,
the regional lymph nodes.
Okay, here's some images. This
is an MRI of the
knee, obviously.
Here's the soft tissues
of the lower thigh, and
you can see the mass
right here. So this one's
actually occurring around
synovial structures, which
made them think synovial
sarcoma in the past.
And here's an image
of the biophasic
pattern with spindle
cells shown here,
INC ratio in these
fascicles, cells,
and then glandular type
structures, you can see the
lumen, and they have cuboidal
to columnar epithelium.
And lastly,
all right, this tumor includes
mesenchymal tumors
with a high grade,
and In pleomorphic
cells, they can't be
classified into any
other histomorphologic or
immunophenotypic or
genetic group based
on molecular studies,
immunohistochemistry,
and looking at the structure
because this is one
of the pleomorphic
tumors, and I mentioned
pleomorphic rhabdomyosycoma.
So, you would use
immunohistochemistry to
stain those two. So this one,
if you look down here,
by definition, they lack
differentiation along recognized
lineages. So the stains
will not stain, and
there's no characteristic
genetic defects. There's
a lot of odd defects, and
there's no consistent pattern
that can be recognized.
So,
and because it's a ovaric
tumor, you know, it's hard
to find tissue that you
can use to help do studies.
This, and so remember some, is
some demographics,
mostly arising.
Okay.
Middle age or older,
and the deep soft
tissues of the
extremity, especially
the thigh, so remember
that location.
and middle-aged,
50 or older, 60,
growing fixed firm,
okay, fixed firm, and
that's because they're
invading other tissues.
Lump or swelling, okay,
so just looking at the
physical exam, yeah, that
could be many different
things. If it grows
very large, there may
be pain, tingling, and
numbness, You know, as
it causes disorder of
surrounding structures.
And if you take out
the tumor and look at
it, they can grow up
to 20 centimeters.
And they usually
have a gray-white,
fleshy appearance of
the mass or masses.
Hemorrhage is common because
undifferentiated pleomorphic
sarcoma, and it will grow
large and rapidly, and
the ulcerative is blood
supply. creating hemorrhages.
So, microscopically,
you're going to see
that, pleomorphic
cells. Pleomorphic means
cells with large
nuclei, small nuclei,
so variation in sizes,
variation in shapes,
odd shapes, and also the
cells themselves. Some
will have a lot of
cytoplasm. Some will be
very small and condensed.
So that's what
pleomorphic is. Variation
in shape and sizes
that are not normal.
So there's going to
be sheets of large
anaplastic spindle
or polygonal cells.
Hyperchromatic irregular,
sometimes bizarre nuclei.
So these are features
of a malignant
type tumor. Mitotic figures,
once again,
malignant type tumor.
Okay.
All right.
And I already mentioned
lack differentiation,
so if you stain the
pneumorphic rhabdo, you
would stain it for Desmond
Myogenin, which would
be positive, and this
one would be negative.
Its aggressive malignancy has
to be treated with surgery,
adjuvant chemo,
and or radiation,
generally poor prognosis.
Tests occur in up
to 50% of cases.
and this is a HNA stained
tissue section of a
tumor and you can see
bizarre mycotic figure
here you can see some of
these cells this one has
two nuclei and they're
very large and this is
a regular this one's a
bit smaller than that
nuclei look at this
nuclei how regular that is
this has a lot of cytoplasm
and you'll find ones
over here with hardly any
cytoplasm and then you know
the scattering of all
different shapes and sizes
of cells with very
irregular nuclei and here's
another abnormal mitotic
figure so we're not going to
mention much about these
other soft tissue tumors
because I've already gone
on and on about the ones
we did but rhabdomyoma so
it says oma and rhabdomyo,
so skeletal muscle tumor,
and benign, commonly.
Remember, if someone asks
you about it, usually
found in the heart,
associated with tuberous
sclerosis, so remember those
characteristic features.
Liomyoma, so lio refers
to smooth muscle,
myoma, myo, and then the
oma part is referring
to a benign type of
smooth muscle tumor,
and it's common, benign
commonly seen in the
uterus, and one of
the more common names
is the fibroids.
Then there's gliomyosarcoma,
so once again, smooth
muscle, but in this case,
it's suddenly got malignant
transformation and has
become invasive, may even
metastasize. So it's a
malignant smooth muscle
tumor, and it's commonly
found in the uterus as well.
Here's a summary slide.
This goes over some general
features of these
different disorders that we
talked about. With the
adipose cell of origin tumors,
the fibroblast origin of
cell of origin tumors,
skeletal muscle origin type
of tumors, and then ones
that have uncertain origin,
the synovial sarcoma
and the undifferentiated
pleomorphic sarcoma. Okay,
so remember, C. snowy
sarcoma, remember that
characteristic
translocation, X18, biphasic,
stained for cytokarotons,
rhabdomyosarcoma,
remember the different
subtypes, this one's
the best prognosis,
sarcoma patroides,
fibrosarcoma, it's a
malignant form of these other
benign processes, but
some of this one, they
can be aggressive, like
deep fibromatosis, and
And a herringbone pattern,
that's characteristic.
Liposarcoma is the malignant
form of the lipoma.
And you might see, and
there's various forms.
And in this case,
you'll find, here
you'll find a mature
adipose tissue.
Here you might see
some lipoblasts.
And that would be it.
Sorry if I went a bit
long. This is a link for
a feedback form. And I
would appreciate that.
And I want to thank you for
your time and attention.